do you feel like this is what you were
meant to do being actors or is there any
other thing I mean I know you're a mom
so that's probably changes so much of
your world view but up until that point
maybe did you feel that that acting is
the only thing for you yeah and I
started acting since before I can
remember just with I have four older
siblings and we all put on plays and did
all of that growing up and entertained
and I grew up dancing since preschool
and singing and grew up in musical
theater and I just no matter I played
sports and I did good in school but
nothing made me excited like the arts
and like acting and I'm not that great
of a singer and I yeah I just naturally
I guess I have always gone back to
acting and it's a therapeutic thing for
me it's it's a wonderful thing to be
able to step into somebody else and
bring your honest opinion out into
someone that lived a different life like
you you get handed this character this
human that you've never met before and
you read about them and you have to try
to show them and create and be this
person that you didn't live that life
but everyone can relate to everyone in
some way or another and it's all about
trying to bring that to life pretty much
it's putting yourself in somebody else's
shoes and trying to make it as real and
as honest for yourself and i love i love
that and i've lived like that my entire
life anytime i'm talking to anybody i
try to truly understand and feel what
they're feeling and
you know be human so the characters for
me it's really fun it's it's fun
homework and it's fun putting it on and
it's fun living in their skin and it's
exhausting
you